それで生命が無知になる過程
なんで頭が悪くなるのかっていうところを説明します
だから まず論理的に見れば
悪くなるはずがないんです
遅い頭も早い頭もあるはずがないんです
しかし 実際は頭悪い人しかいません
だったらどうなっているのかということ
データの関連性っていうことで学んでみましょう
眼耳鼻舌身意にそれぞれ入る一つのデータに関連がある無数のデータが心のデータバンクにある
ちょっと文章を間違ってるかもしれませんだけど
この眼耳鼻舌身意に同じデータ入るわけじゃないんです
それぞれデータが違うんです
目に入るものでも 目に入るものは違いますからね
とにかくデータが一つ入ったら
そのデータに関連性がある無数のデータがデータバンクにあるんです
心の中で すべては取り出せないんですよ
例えば 鳥の声を聞いてカラスだと認識しても
一生聞いているカラスの声を思い出すわけじゃありません
だからと言って何か取り出せば良いということもないんですよ
だから 知識にするためには過去のデータを取り出さないと
取り出して合成しないと
だからといって関連性あるすべてのデータを取り出すということは
ちょっと話にならないし
何でもいいんだから何か取り出して合成しましょうと
知識にしましょうということもそれほどいいわけじゃないんですね
しかし 情報 知識 まあ知識にしなくてはならないんですね
知識に概念にすることは瞬間に起こるんですよ
だから心は早いんだから
入ったデータを知識にしなくちゃいけないんです
これはもう決まりです
聞いた音をこの音だと決めておけないと
瞬時に決めちゃうんです
すごく早いんです 声が聞いた途端
カラスと決めることっていうのはものすごい早い
そこはもうやめることはできません
ということは 我々が入るデータは瞬時に知識化しなくちゃいかない
この瞬時に知識化するために
過去のデータを取り出さなくちゃいけない
そういう大変なことになっています
だから取り出すんですよ
取り出して意識化します
認識します そういうわけで
このレスピレーションオブマインドということで
心の焦りですね  1 秒の100分の2ぐらいの速さで知識概念を作らなくてはならないので
心は常に焦るんです これは仏教用語でうっちゃなんですね
だから認識しないでいることは不可能ですよ
これはもうお釈迦様の瞑想に達していない限りは
世の中の瞑想でもできません
認識しないでいることはブッダの瞑想だけなんです
それはお釈迦様ははっきり言っています
世の中誰にもできるのかと
認識を止めることはと
そういうわけだから もう認識するということは
もう世の中いろいろ宗教家が瞑想の法たちいっぱいいたんですけど
ここまで行ってないんです
わかってもないんでしょうしね
だから認識することは
瞬時に 1 秒の 100分の1で2に起きているんです
これ  1 秒の 100分の1っていうのは
これ私勝手に言ってる単語で
実際はもっと早いんだそうです
それははっきり計算 現代我々にわかるような計算したところはないんで
ただ瞬間瞬間という瞬間シャナですね
という単語を使っているだけで
何でもいいから適当に無作為に過去のデータと組み合わせて知識にするんです
だから 本当は何でもいいわけないでしょうに
まあもうちゃんとした論文を書くということで例えてみてください
いくらが関連あるんだからといって
もう何でも適当に入れて
もう枚数だけ字数だけ合わせたっても
そんなの意味がないでしょう
もし焦ってる学生だったら
全然もう関連性もなく
ただ枚数だけ増やしてもう出したりする
しかし 論文を書くならば大量にデータがあるんですけど
自分研究するテーマに
自分が出そうとする結論に必要なデータを取って
丁寧に組み合わせて丁寧に合成して出さなくちゃいけない
それは立派な論文になります
知識の場合も同じことなんで
論文形式なんですよ 知識はしっかりしなくちゃいけないんだけど
これ時間ないんですよ
もう締め切りなんですね
瞬間に 1 秒の 100 分の 1 でもう締め切りですからね
ですから もう何でもいいんだから認識しちゃうんです
焦る人の知識は一貫性がありません
そういうわけで 生命は焦ってます
自然に焦らずにいられないんです
これ 心の法則なんです
心はデータが入ったら資格が生まれてすぐ認識する
だから次の瞬間で認識しなくちゃいけないんで
まあ砂で言えばだいたい 6つぐらい時間ありますけどね
刹那で言えばね 刹那で言えば
6つの刹那ぐらいは まあそうやって時間もありますけどね
でお釈迦様は 3つで認識する
終わるんです だから人間の生命の中でブッダの方が一番早いみたいんです
だから刹那もう百 もう 1千 10 万ぐらいになってくると
1 秒の 100 分の 1 ぐらいですからね
まあ一応一般的に まあ大雑把にもう我々のは 1 秒の 100 分の 1 でもね
まああの あのデジタル時計見たって見えませんでしょうね
時計あるでしょ？あの 0.00 で動いている
えっ？うん そこは見えません
次になんでしたっけ？感情と理性の対立
前のページで皆様は何を理解するべきかということは
我々の知識は一貫性がないんです
いい加減です データの処理は理性的に行うものですので
心は本来理性的であるはずです
ちゃんとしたデータバンクがあって
インデックスがあって
そこからデータを取って認識にするんだから
ちゃんとしたプロセスなんですよ
まあ全くコンピュータープログラムみたい同じきっちり
論理的にアルゴリズムでできてないと動かないんです
でも我々は動いているんですよ
心は パンクすることはないでしょうに
ですから 本来はものすごい厳密に論理的なんです
そういうことというのは
教育場ではよく使うでしょう
何かもう覚えにくい何かリストとか何とかあると
なんかやけに覚えやすい関連性作ったりしたりするでしょうし
いろいろエピソードを作って
例えば仏教経典の場合は確実にエピソードがあって
エピソードの中に埋めていくんですよ
だから覚えているんです
私もそのその一つ一つ経典にエピソード一つ一つあるんです
だからもう何のことなく思い出そうと思っても
すぐ思い出せるんです
学校では教育の現場でもよくやっていることで
それなんでエピソード作ってそちらに埋め込むか
そこで論理構成ができちゃうんですね
しかし 生命は感情 煩悩に支配されているんです
大きな問題っていうのは
この余計なもの これ異物なんですよ
生命に 生命の心に何か外来的に異物が入り込んでるんです
感情という それに支配されているんです
だから ヤドリギに元の木を倒せますね
自然の経験ないんだから
例えばにしても言いにくい
私には 威張ってこのビニール箱の中に生活していますけどね
で ヤドリギってあってね
まああの木の上でもう自分で枝だけ伸ばして大きくなるんですからね
どんどんもういくらでも栄養あるんだから
元の木で それでもうどんどん大きくなると
もう自分の枝はしっかりしています
自分が何の上に立っているのかっていうと
あまり考えませんね それで木丸ごとね
どーんと倒れちゃいますよ
ヤドリギっていうのは根は木の中に入れますからね
そんな感じで 我々の心にこの煩悩というものをね
感情というもの 入り込んで支配されているんですね
感情は反理性的なんです
だから本来にあってはならないものなんです
心には まあこれから書いてありますけど
これは心に対して猛毒なんですよ
だからウイルスが入ったような感じです
理性的に働く心に反理性的なものが入っちゃうと
もう話になりません 感情がデータ処理するから
知識はおかしいものになるんです
そこで感情に支配されているんだから
感情がデータ処理するんです
過去の経験 感情が引き出すんです
自分も好きなもの というわけで
認識はおかしいんです
愛着 欲 怒り 嫉妬 慢というのは自我ですね
脅威感 脅迫感 落ち込みなどなど感情がいっぱいあります
1500もありますからね
といっても 貪瞋痴では３つでしょうし
まあいくらかあります
まあ心理仏教心理学では一応14人はしています
明確に分けていますからね
これは一つも理性的じゃないでしょ？論理的でもないでしょ
だから心とはもう感情には微塵も理性はありません
感情的な人を説得することも不可能ですでしょ
普通の論理的な話だったら
異論があっても話し合って間違っていて
ああ それはやっぱり間違っているんだということもできますけど
感情的だったらどうしますかね
どうにもならないんですね
非論理的な主観的な概念が知識として心の中に固く記憶されるんですね
悪いことに感情で知識を作ったら
これが絶対変えられないものだからね
変えられる方法もないんだから
非論理的だから これが知識として心に残っちゃうの
かたくなく だから次に引き出す場合はそれを引き出すんです
だから感情で何かこれは綺麗やとか何とか認識しちゃうと
次にそれを思い出すんです
これから入る情報は主観で知識化するので
限りなく客観的な事実から離れています
離れます 感情が割り込んだところで感情が認識しちゃう
その認識も記憶データバンクに行く
行っても その記憶はなかなか死んだりもしないのは愚痴ですからね
あまりにも頑固なんですね
だから固執することを大きな問題というふうに仏教を知っているのはそういうことなんです
次に次にいくら認識したっても
あればっかり出てくるんです
感情で認識した過去のデータ
例えば 我々は自分の過去で何を覚えているかというと
感情的なものしか覚えていないでしょうね
先生が教えたものだったら
きれいさっぱり忘れているでしょうね
大事なことを役に立つことを教えたら
これはもうもう椅子から立ち上がるともう忘れています
しかし この講演で私が腹が立つこととか何とか言ったならば
それだけ覚えて帰るんですよ
そういうふうに心ができているんです
だから思い出そうとしちゃうと
あんな変なデータ おかしいデータしか出てこないんですよ
これではもう生きていられないことになります
正しく